quais os sintomas da fibromialgia e qual
o tratamento e a segunda pergunta ela
pode afetar o cérebro bem a moto
passando Que beleza né a fibromialgia é
uma condição crônica que afeta o sistema
nervosocentral sim causa dor
generalizada no corpo e outros sintomas
debilitantes Então vamos falar aqui dos
sintomas mais comuns o mais conhecido de
todos é a dor generalizada é uma dor que
tem vários pontos focais vários pontos
gatilhos Mas é uma dor crônica uma dor
difusa atinge quase todo o organismo
especialmente músculos tendões e
articulações então tem aluns pontos
específicos né os Trigger points que
quando pressionados causam dor intensa
isso é um critério diagnóstico da
fibromialgia outro sintoma como é a
fadiga crônica e falta de energia
disturbo de sono também é muito comum
pessoas que TM fibromialgia bastante
comum Tem insônia e problemas cognitivos
o chamado nevoeiro mental ou neva ment
mental né o Brain fog que leva a
dificuldade de concentração memória ruim
confusão mental e também aumento de
sensibilidade sensibilidade aumentada a
estímulos como luz som e temperatura é
um sintoma depressão e ansiedade também
é muito comum